we're working here in the framework of
the
publications office inter-institutional
committee
and it's all eu institutions and
committees who are faced with the same
problem which is basically how to deal
with
digital revolution and ebooks in
particular we have to adjust our
production to the needs of our readers
so knowing the market is quite useful
knowing the dissemination constraints is
also very useful to us we collectively
is the institutions and bodies of the
european union have to think about do
our
short time
life publications should they all go to
digital instead of being the traditional
print and we also have to think about
distribution channels that you have to
be very very selective in who your
audience is in order to be successful in
developing a relationship with your
readers
those people picking up ebooks at first
are not the geeks who are fond of their
gadgets but this is about reading those
who are the the
strongest readers who have the largest
reading load and that applies of course
also for professional reading and the
european commission
has
tons of very valuable material
which can be proposed to readers who
want to have a more convenient
experience in accessing these materials
you're bringing people together who see
similar problems from different
perspectives that's number one it's a
it's a genuine sharing it's a search for
some kind of consensus the other thing
is that it's information sharing in a
context where the technology is changing
so quickly that we all need to to keep
up to speed if we want to find more uh
publications coming from the from the
public office
irrigation officer in luxembourg then i
think that
the eu civil servants have to work
directly with librarians and explain
them what is europe what europe is doing
and how these documents are available
and to inform the librarians themselves
that these documents are available for
free people can access to them via
public libraries the point about the
ebook market and dissemination is that
today from a global perspective is being
driven by the main players
that are providing the devices the one
who are driving the e-book market today
in terms of formats as well as in terms
of of final devices when you look at it
more from a european perspective you
need to focus on each single country
why simply because the digital value
chain for ebook distribution is being
localized this is why we need from a
local perspective as well as from a
global perspective
work through the different
players of a digital value chain if
we're not
heading towards an ecosystem and open
standard and open solutions then it'll
mean that we'll be very limited
in terms of
how we discover books how we acquire
books and i think the the having a
standard having something that really
works like an ecosystem is the only way
to have the kind of diversity we have
today in the book word the publication
office needs to
work with other partners but also to
maximize its accessibility of its own
character
thank you